so I'm curious if 16 is an adult in your
view why does this bill have the minor
defined as 18. yeah that's that's a hit
piece you took from Media Matters uh
from something when I was a radio host
uh 13 14 years ago in my early 20s it's
also not an accurate reflection of what
I actually said I was talking about the
fact that people tended to marry young
historically and that's all that that
was about how does that relate to this
subject just curious your definition of
if you feel like people are adults at 16
should people are adults at 18. uh but
actually they're your your brain is not
fully developed until you're 25.
so we should be having a conversation
about whether we should even be doing
these surgeries to people at 18. but
certainly before 18 it's it's absurd I
mean do you do you think that a 16 year
old can meaningfully consent to having
their body parts removed
do you
no